et c'est en tant que président de la
fête de l'île aux enfants que je suis
heureux d'inaugurer en ce jour cette
sirène d'alarmé qui permettra aux
habitants de l'île d'obtenir aide et
secours dans des délais leaf le coût
de ce jour mémorable sépare les hommes
ne se sentira isoler le moindre incident
trouvera aussitôt un terme favorable et
un terme final mais bravo
le moment est venu
mais très chers amis de faire un essai
probants et concluant et nos oreilles
bien dressés avons déjà prêt d'être
bercer par le doux chant de cette sirène
ultra moderne
qui va la faire fonctionner monsieur 19
et je vous propose
émile campagne vous fait peur la vidéo
darfour il sans arrêt lille en tous sens
et il est donc hors europe je voulais
deux incidents pour sûr françois je suis
très touchée de votre faveur
mais la distribution de courrier ne
saurait souffrir une autre occupation
même béliveau mon devoir est de refuser
par cet horizon facteurs pour faire
fonctionner la sirène il faudrait
quelqu'un de libre
quelqu'un de dévoué quelqu'un d'efficace
tels que linger merci transformer notre
fatigue pas
j'ai tout de suite compris quand tu
voulais parler de moi et casimir je n'ai
pas terminé ma phrase donc je voulais
ajouter efficace et connaissent pas mais
vas-y continue j'adore les compliments
bon et bien casé va-t-on mes très chers
amis pour la première fois faire
fonctionner cette série
tout est joué
tu sais léonard si j'avais beaucoup
d'argent
j'achèterais un gros gâteau pour le mot
j'ai tiens pardi et après après quoi en
avoir mangé après l'avoir mangé
j'achèterais un deuxième gros gâteau
c'est pourquoi fait pour manger tiens
pardi bouquet et après après quoi et
l'appoint de manger
après l'avoir mangé
j'achèterais un troisième gros gâteau
- tu aurais encore envie d'un gâteau
après en avoir mangé deux je crois que
oui culture n'est sûr comment veux tu
que j'en sois sûr
je crois qu oui
maintenant mais tous que tu es beaucoup
d'action oui oui
que tu achètes trois gros gâteau que tu
n'aimes ans qu'est-ce que tu ferais
frais
après oui
je me paierais un grand bol de chocolat
au lait pour faire passer mes trois gros
gâteau et un prêt
après oui
après ben je m'achèterai dé glace au
caramel à la vanille au chocolat à la
fraise à la pistache ça rafraîchit
et après après oui
après on sait rien on sait rien du tout
après
olala léonard oui oh je suis malade
si mal au coeur j'ai mal au ventre fait
mal à l'estomac
c'est à cause de toutes ces glaces de ce
chocolat et des gâteaux oh là là je vais
vite aller prendre un cachet pour
digérer tout ça moi en alabama
[Musique]
tiens ça c'est curieux j'avais posé mes
nouveaux bonbons sur le bord du quai
qu'est-ce que j'en ai fais tu as perdu
quel ton change du livre m'avait non ce
n'est rien casimir mais j'ai dû oublier
mes nouveaux bonbons chez moi ou ou au
port mais ce n'est pas rien c'est très
grave enfin je comptais compter ces
nouveaux bonbons aujourd'hui mais tu
sais de la simple et même une heure une
catastrophe dit
qu'à ses murs tuer mais qu'est ce que tu
fais est prête à tout
je lis va nous arranger de la
catastrophe presque
c'est à dire que que j'avais égaré mais
nouveau bon bout quoi est due tout ça
dérange et pour
s'assurer
le grand chêne du coup selon lequel il
faut pas faire fonctionner la sirène
pour rien
enfin je ne savais pas franchement bon
coup je te promets je ne l'utiliserai
plus inutilement bon bah il ne reste
plus qu'à repartir ou arrêtés en train
de prendre super beau tableau
coucher de soleil embrase et le sol est
un sel 2000 pour voir embrasé mis fin il
ne faut pas perdre son temps vite mais
préparez-vous soit dont des émirs
pourquoi nous nous y voyons embrasé
mille fois mais c'est très grave à aller
chercher de l'eau il faut jacques est
descendu sur le tabou de monsieur de
snob pour casimir décidément je crois
que tu n'as rien compris désormais il
est préférable qu'il une approche plus
jamais de cette série s'est terminée
sans rage et compris vous vous êtes tous
ligués contre moi pour me prendre ma
place bon et bien puisque plus personne
dans même ici je n'ai plus qu'à partir
puisque je suis inutile je n'ai vraiment
rien à faire et c'est tant pis six mois
françoise
wiki at il joué je trouve que tu étais
un peu brusque que tout à l'heure avec
casimir
par moment il ne fait que des bêtises
oui mais il aurait peut être mieux valu
lui expliquer en détail ce qu'il fallait
faire
j'avoue que j'ai un peu perdu patience
bon ben téléphonie devenir moi je
rassemble les enfants tu es gentil
j'appelle tout petit
alors allo casimir à julie dis moi
monsieur du snob et françois tout à
l'heure sont un peu énervés mais il le
regrette alors tu peux venir tout de
suite parce que tu vas pouvoir à nouveau
est occupé de la sirène bon alors si
c'est toi qui m'as la demande
personnellement
j'accepte d'accord arrivent
ils arrivent tout si parfait emploi
voilà vis à vis à vis à vis de casimir
je vais demander aux enfants pourquoi on
se sert d'une sirène mais c'est très
intéressant ça les enfants dans quelles
circonstances ce certains d'une sirène
oui tu as raison quand il ya un incendie
a noyé quand ils noyade oui quelles
circonstances encore
longue et divers accidents notamment des
d accidents de la route et une fois
qu'on a fait fonctionner la sirène
quelles sont les personnes qu'on voit al
tahrir et
il est ok pour un incendie mais demeure
la police la gendarmerie
voilà exactement une ambulance avec les
ambulanciers il sait casimir on donne un
goût de sirène pour un feu de cheminée
deux coups de sirène pour une noyade ou
un accident de la route trois coups de
sirène pour un incendie et quatre coups
de sirène pour un gros incendie bon bah
écoutes je m'en souviendrai c'est
parfait je vais enfin ça va faire
marcher la sirène et je te promets je ne
me tromperai plus tant mieux
soit quand ils julie françois les
enfants m'ont tout expliquer je saurai à
un excellent gardien de sirène suis bien
contente casimir tissait dix mois il ya
peut-être quelque chose que françois
oublié de te dire c'est important oui
très important toutes les semaines le
même jour à la même heure on fait
marcher la sirène même s'il n'y a pas d'
incendies ni d'accident oui bien sûr
c'est pour s'assurer qu'elles
fonctionnent bien 1
on n'a pas encore fixé ni l'heure ni le
jour à non pas encore alors ça pourra
être aujourd'hui et maintenant à
casimir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai joué j'ai dit est ce que tu t'es
pas au chili
au quasi que ces stages est
l'un des fiefs